Ich bin sehr stolz,
der Künstler zu sein,
der die Latinmusik in der Schweiz
so gross gemacht hat.
Ich bin stolz,
diese Türe geöffnet zu haben.
Und ich bin stolz,
dass ich als Latino diese Vibes
in diesem Land repräsentieren darf.
Der Hauptrepräsentant zu sein,
macht mich stolz.
# Si tu me dices:
Ya no mas ya me voy.
Alle:
- (Alle) # Nena no te voy a parar.
Grosse Töne,
aber auch grosse Erfolge,
zumindest in der Schweiz.
Musiker Loco Escrito holt bisher
viermal Platin und einmal Gold.
Anfang Jahr gewinnt der Schweizer
mit kolumbianischen Wurzeln
überraschend einen Swiss Music Award.
Du möchtest nicht nur
hier weitermachen,
sondern expandieren,
nach Südamerika gehen.
D.h., dein jetziger Erfolg
genügt dir nicht?
Nein.
Für mich ist das noch kein Erfolg.
Manche Leute sagen,
ich sei mega erfolgreich,
aber ich selbst
sehe mich noch nicht dort.
An Selbstvertrauen
mangelt es Loco Escrito,
der eigentlich Nicolas Herzig heisst,
nicht.
Siegessicher will er von
seinem Geburtsland Kolumbien aus
ein grosser Latin-Star werden.
Ob er dem ambitionierten Vorhaben
gewachsen ist,
davon handelt dieser Film.
Hier in Wetzikon Zürich
ist Nicolas aufgewachsen.
Seit drei Jahren ist er Vater.
Von der Mutter des Kindes
lebt er getrennt.
Das Sorgerecht für Tochter Aisha
teilen sich die beiden.
Mehrmals pro Woche
besucht er seine Mutter.
Hoi, Ma!
Hoi!
- Hoi.
Wie geht's?
- Gut. Und dir?
Gut. Ich habe Fleisch gekauft.
Hast du noch Cola?
Isabelle Herzig erinnert sich:
Schon als Kind wollte Nicolas
immer mit dem Kopf durch die Wand.
Das dauert schon 15 Min.
Ich habe extrem Hunger.
Ich habe extrem Hunger,
einen Bärenhunger habe ich.
Es hat immer Sachen gegeben,
die er unbedingt erreichen wollte.
Er hat dann jeweils so lange geübt,
bis er es konnte.
Er hat nie aufgegeben. Nicht wahr?
Ausser,
wenn es zu lange gedauert hat.
Nein, was du sagst, stimmt.
Ich wollte z.B.
einen Salto machen können.
Da hat er geübt
und geübt und geübt ...
Zu Hause ...
- Ich bin auf den Nacken gefallen.
Ja. Den Headspin
wollte er auch unbedingt können.
Das ist,
wenn man sich auf dem Kopf dreht.
Ich habe einfach immer
alles ausprobiert.
Mir hat immer geholfen,
dass ich keine Angst hatte.
Ich hatte z.B. nie Angst,
mich zu verletzen.
Nein, Angst hatte er nie.
Bei der Musik ist es das Gleiche.
Es hilft auch im Sport.
Es hilft bei allem,
wenn man keine Angst hat.
Er hatte nie Angst,
bei Ski fahren, beim Schlitteln ...
Plötzlich war der kleine Nico weg,
er ging ganz alleine hinunter.
Einst hat sie sechs Jahre
in Kolumbien gelebt,
in der Heimat von Nicolas' Vater.
In Medellin haben sie Tochter Joanna
und dann Nicolas bekommen.
Kurz nach seiner Geburt
sind sie zurück in die Schweiz.
Wie ist es für dich,
dass dein Sohn eine solche Sehnsucht
nach Kolumbien hat?
Ist das manchmal schwierig?
Nein, ich verstehe das.
Er wollte schon sehr früh
die Sprache richtig lernen.
Ich denke,
wenn man in die Pubertät kommt,
ist man auch auf der Suche
nach seiner Identität.
Er hat sich sehr
damit auseinandergesetzt.
Ich finde das gut.
Auch Nicolas' jüngerer Bruder
ist von Kolumbien fasziniert.
Vor einem Jahr wandert Diego aus.
Meine Güte, Nico!
Davon nimmst du nicht viel, oder?
- Nein. Oops!
Guten Appetit, Ma.
Sieht sehr schön aus. Guten Appetit.
Optisch der Schweizer,
im Herzen der Paisa.
Nicolas identifiziert sich
mit den Bewohnern Medellins.
Paisas haben ihren eigenen Slang,
eigene Essensgerichte, und man sagt,
sie seien von der Arbeitsmoral her
Büezer.
Der Latino
hat grundsätzlich eine Mentalität,
die er in Medellin
vielleicht etwas weniger hat.
Dort sind sie nicht so ...
Das war schon immer so,
das ist die Arbeiterregion.
Nicht die Arbeiterregion,
sie haben einfach Ideen und pushen.
Es war die Arbeiterregion,
deshalb gibt es auch die Paisas.
Ja, aber ... Ich meine ...
Wenn man Arbeiter sagt,
ist vielleicht nicht klar,
was man meint.
Sie haben immer Ideen, Impulse.
Sie pushen.
Das ist der Paisa, sagt man immer.
Derjenige, der ...
... der vorwärts geht,
der wie ich denkt.
Man hat nur ein Leben,
deshalb sollte man jeden Tag
das Maximum geben
und keine Zeit verschwenden.
So sind die Leute von Medellin.
Mit der Einstellung eines Paisas
und der Vision vom Weltruhm
reist der Zürcher Oberländer
für einen Monat nach Medellin.
* Pulsierende Musik *
Schon am ersten Tag
steht ein Kennenlernen
mit dem Musikunternehmen
Sony Music Kolumbien an.
* Sie sprechen spanisch. *
Der 29-Jährige ist mit seinem Team
aus der Schweiz angereist.
Das sind: sein DJ, Coiffeur und
Social-Media-Experte in einem:
Engels Rodriguez.
Musikproduzent Henrik Amschler
und Manager Fabio Menzi.
* Sie sprechen spanisch.*
Loco Escrito ist hier ein Niemand.
Nicolas muss
dem künstlerischen Leiter erklären,
wer er ist und welche Erfolge
er in der Schweiz feiern durfte.
Und er zeigt ihm seine grössten Hits.
# Porque yo les cai.
Porque yo les cai.
# L-O-C-O escrito.
Al principio todo estaba en orden.
# Me sentia muy enamorado.
# Antes me ponias tu muy contento.
# Ahora pones problemas,
ya estoy cansado.
# Ciao! Dime cuantas veces
has dicho que me dejas,
# pero no desapareces.
# Tranquila, bien pueda ...
Sehr gut.
Du machst nichts auf
Schweizerdeutsch? Rein gar nichts?
Nein, das ist nicht mein Ding.
Es ist sehr ungewöhnlich,
dass einer,
der nicht hier aufgewachsen ist,
diesen Klang so hinbekommt.
Er macht's richtig gut.
Ich bin etwas überrascht.
Ich sehe eine grosse Zukunft.
Einen Rat gibt er ihm aber:
Nicolas soll den Schweizer markieren.
Das sagt er gerade ihm,
dem stolzen Paisa,
der endlich
unter seinesgleichen ist.
Wieso? Was ist der Grund?
Es gibt so viele Artisten hier.
Du bist aus der Schweiz,
das ist dein Vorteil.
Du bist der Ausländer auf Besuch.
Wieso?
Wir brauchen nicht noch mehr.
In der Schweiz erzählen wir aber
eine andere Geschichte. - Ja.
Dort sehen sie, dass ich
meine Herkunft nicht verleugne.
Ja, behalte das dort bei.
- Sie verfolgen, was ich hier mache.
Wenn ich nicht aufpasse, heisst es:
"Wieso gehst du nicht ..."
Dort verkaufst du dich gut.
Versuche nicht,
hier der super Paisa zu sein.
Okay.
Ich sage: "Hello, how are you?"
Oder auf Deutsch.
- Guten Tag.
Ganz ehrlich,
es wird schwierig werden.
Ich bin ein stolzer Kolumbianer,
aber ich werde mich zurücknehmen
und z.B. auf Englisch grüssen.
Es geht nicht um Stolz,
es ist eine Strategie.
Du nutzt, dass du von dort kommst.
Es ist wie im Film.
Jeder spielt eine Rolle,
die nicht real ist.
Es ist nur eine Rolle.
Ist Kolumbien vielleicht
doch eine Nummer zu gross?
Ich verstehe v.a.,
dass man zuerst einmal
die Aufmerksamkeit wecken muss.
Es wird einfach mega schwierig.
Wenn ich jeweils nicht mit
dem kolumbianischen Pass einreise,
schaffe ich es auch nicht,
auf Tourist zu machen.
Es ist nicht einfach,
das umzusetzen.
Sie meinen nicht,
dass ich verleugnen soll,
dass ich mich in Kolumbien
Zu Hause fühle.
Ich soll einfach
das Exotische beibehalten.
Er ist recht begeistert, ja.
Sehr sogar.
Wenn wohl auch widerwillig
nimmt er den Tipp -
zusammen mit Schweizer Schoggi -
mit auf einen Medien-Marathon.
* Ansage auf spanisch. *
So geil,
jetzt sind wir hier bei La Mega.
# Ya ni se como se siente
de tenerte aca a mi lado.
Auch das Polizei-Radio
heisst die Schweizer willkommen.
Du lebst in der Schweiz,
aber dein Akzent ist fehlerfrei.
Das ist wegen meines Vaters.
Den Akzent hab ich nicht verloren,
aber viele Wörter.
Seinen Sieg eines Swiss Music Awards
macht er gerne zum Thema.
Ich bin zurzeit der
beliebteste Künstler in der Schweiz.
Ich bin
ein wichtiges Aushängeschild:
Ich bringe den Latino-Sound
nach Europa.
Ob die Kolumbianer auch an
seine Träume glauben, bleibt unklar.
Dieser Monat wird bestimmt von
Medienterminen und Kontakteknüpfen.
Trotz dichtem Programm
besucht Nicolas seinen Vater,
der wieder hier lebt.
Wie lange hast du deinen Vater
nicht gesehen?
Drei Jahre.
Das sind jetzt schon drei Jahre.
Eine lange Zeit.
- Eine lange Zeit, ja.
Du warst drei Jahre
nicht in Kolumbien,
obwohl es deine Heimat ist.
Meine Tochter ist vor drei Jahren
auf die Welt gekommen. Und ...
Ich wollte sie gerne mitnehmen,
aber solange sie noch so klein ist,
ist es nicht gut, wenn sie so lange
von der Mutter getrennt ist.
Zudem haben wir
in den letzten drei Jahren
in der Schweiz unser Business
entwickelt und alles aufgebaut.
Jetzt sind wir in der Schweiz
schon mega weit oben.
Man muss den Fokus dort setzen,
wo die Arbeit ist.
Dort ist unser tägliches Brot,
sage ich immer.
Mittlerweile
kann Nicolas von der Musik leben.
Der pensionierte Vater wohnt
in einem der besseren Viertel
zusammen mit seiner Freundin
und den beiden Hunden.
* Bellen *
Hola!
* Sie sprechen spanisch. *
Wenn man einen Menschen
seit der Geburt kennt,
freut man sich mega
auf den Moment des Wiedersehens.
Jetzt bin ich da
und alles ist im guten Sinn normal.
Wenn ich hierher komme,
komme ich nach Hause.
Ihr sitzt sogar gleich da.
Viele Leute sagen auch,
dass wir ähnlich sprechen.
Wenn ich hier ans Telefon gehe,
werde ich oft mit ihm verwechselt.
Früher hatten wir beide
viele Schrauben locker,
jetzt nicht mehr so.
Ich habe viel erlebt im Leben.
Ich habe vieles gemacht.
Ich hatte mehrere Motorradunfälle.
Wir beide lieben Motorräder.
Kennst du mein neues Motorrad?
Nur vom Video. Es spuckt Feuer.
- Es spuckt Feuer.
Ich sollte jetzt
nicht Motorrad fahren.
Fernando Herzig ist vor rund zehn
Jahren in die Heimat zurückgekehrt.
Heute ist Medellin sicherer geworden.
Jahrzehntelang aber hielt
das Drogenkartell unter Pablo Escobar
die 2,5-Millionen-Metropole im Griff.
* Sie sprechen spanisch. *
Als Kind hatte ich grosse Angst,
entführt zu werden.
Ein Cousin meiner Mutter
wurde entführt und zerstückelt.
Man hat ihn
im Kofferraum eines Autos gefunden.
Das hat mich sehr geprägt.
Fernando erzählt vom Bombenangriff
auf das Wohnhaus Escobars,
von einem Raubüberfall,
dem sie nur knapp entkommen sind,
von Bildern toter Menschen,
die sich bis heute
in sein Gedächtnis gebrannt haben.
Ich hab zwei dieser Mörder
am Boden gesehen.
Sie waren tot.
Ich sehe immer noch seine Schuhe.
Schon mein ganzes Leben lang.
Und trotzdem haben wir hier
sehr schön gelebt.
Jetzt reicht es aber
mit diesen Geschichten.
Wegen Pablo Escobar
sind 5'000 Leute getötet worden.
5'000!
Ein Viertel
der Einwohnerzahl von Wetzikon.
Nicolas will von der blutigen
Vergangenheit nichts wissen.
Er sieht sich als neue Generation
von Paisas, die voraus blickt.
Einfach für jemanden,
der behütet aufgewachsen ist.
Stolz ist er
auf das heutige Medellin.
Die Stadt gilt als eine
der innovativsten Städte der Welt.
Dazu beigetragen
haben neue Transportmittel
wie Gondeln und Rolltreppen.
Die abgeschiedenen Armenviertel
werden so
mit dem öffentlichen Leben verbunden.
Zum ersten Mal
getraut sich Nicolas nun
ins berüchtigte Bandenviertel
Comuna 13.
Diese Rolltreppe lässt
das gefährliche Quartier aufleben
und lockt Touristen an.
Betreten sollte man
die Comuna 13
sicherheitshalber
dennoch nur mit einem Guide.
Komm, komm, zur Kamera!
Mit wem bist du hier?
* Sie sprechen spanisch. *
Vom Banden-Tourismus angesteckt,
planen Nicolas mit seinem Bruder
und einem Schweizer Filmteam
den Dreh eines Videoclips.
Machst du noch ein vertikales?
Da machen wir auch mal eine Story.
Geiler Scheiss!
Ich bin zum ersten Mal hier oben.
Früher war diese Gegend tabu.
Es ist immer noch ...
Wenn man sich am falschen Ort eines
Sektors aufhält, ist es vorbei.
Hier oben regieren Banden.
Jeder muss in seinem Sektor bleiben,
sonst gibt es Probleme.
Scheisse, nachher ist man weiss.
Das ist ein Problem,
aber sie geht nicht weg im Wasser.
* Sie sprechen spanisch. *
Wir nehmen die Steadycam.
Ich werde einfach laufen.
Es ist saugeil hier.
Armut und Bandenkriminalität:
Sie mindern seine Begeisterung nicht.
Als Paisa träumt er
von einem Leben in Medellin.
Wenn es aber um die Tochter geht,
ist Nicolas wieder Schweizer.
Möchtest du deine Tochter
hier aufwachsen sehen?
Ja, schon, aber nur -
und da differenziere ich klar,
weil ich halt Schweizer bin ...
Sie kann ja in einem sicheren Land
wie der Schweiz aufwachsen.
Ich würde sie nur hierher bringen,
wenn ich genügend Geld hätte,
sie auf eine gute Schule zu schicken
und für ihre Sicherheit zu sorgen.
An der Schweiz schätze ich, dass
meine Tochter draussen spielen kann
und man von A nach B gehen kann,
ohne sich Sorgen zu machen.
Solche Dinge
fehlen mir als Schweizer hier.
Manche Dinge wären problematisch,
wenn ich hier mit ihr leben würde.
Treppen gibt es auch zu viele.
Die Tage
dauern meist bis in die Nacht.
Parallel arbeitet
der Schweizer Musikproduzent
mit einer
kolumbianischen Produktionsfirma
in der gemieteten Finca
an neuen Songs.
* Sie sprechen spanisch. *
Vom Team fordert Nicolas
einen unerbittlichen Arbeitseifer.
* Lateinamerikanische Musik *
Was muss passieren,
damit du glücklich nach Hause reist?
Ich wäre dann unglücklich, wenn wir
etwas vernachlässigt hätten,
aber das machen wir nicht.
Unser Produkt Loco Escrito
ist wie ein Baby,
wir der Kleine meines Bruders,
man macht einfach alles dafür.
Solange alles gut geht,
reise ich gut zurück.
* Lateinamerikanische Musik *
Musik und Familie - das sind
die beiden Pfeiler in Nicolas' Leben.
Ja, schau mal, Dante!
* Lateinamerikanische Musik *
Zwei Monate später,
Zu Hause im zürcherischen Grüt.
Ein Durchbruch in Lateinamerika
ist noch nicht in Sicht.
Einige Radios in Kolumbien spielen
nun aber ab und zu seine Lieder.
Auch die Kontakte
pflegt Nicolas weiter.
Der Fokus auf die Musik
hat sich verstärkt,
und das Selbstbewusstsein
ist ungebrochen.
Mittlerweile
habe ich nur noch Kollegen,
die mit Musik zu tun haben.
Du kannst keinen normalen Alltag
leben und gleichzeitig
einer der einflussreichsten
Latin-Urban-Künstler werden.
Das geht nicht.
In Kolumbien
wollte man ihm den Paisa austreiben
und seine Schweizer Seite betonen.
Aber Loco Escrito ist keiner,
der sich gern
etwas vorschreiben lässt.
Ich mache sowieso nie,
was andere mir sagen,
und sei es der Präsident
von wo auch immer.
Ich mache immer,
was ich für richtig halte.
Wenn ich eine Idee schlecht finde,
lasse ich es,
v.a. wenn mich
der Ratgeber kaum kennt.
Scheitern gehört offenbar nicht
ins Konzept von Nicolas Herzig.
Als ich nach Kolumbien ging,
war ich sehr nervös.
Es war mein erster
Interview-Marathon auf Spanisch.
Das nächste Mal
wird es entspannter sein.
Wir wissen jetzt, was wir können,
und wir werden
das nächste Level erreichen.
Es bleibt ein weiter Weg
zum Welterfolg:
Auf Loco Escrito
hat in Kolumbien niemand gewartet.
Mit seinem eisernen Willen
wird Nicolas Herzig
so schnell jedenfalls nicht aufgeben.